que s'est il passé près d'un canal
la recherche se poursuit pour quatre
détenus qui se sont échappés de la carte
de cd rom de maintenance tuant deux
gardes armés et un détenu alors qu'elle
conduisait les autorités affirment que
les impôts par des excréments
et un ta musique s'il te plaît
qu'est ce qu'elle fait là elle c'est
très gentil de partager ton père avec
nous non
tu la laisses tu marches et il a 13 ans
je cherche une clé est là ce symbole
gravé dessus vous l'avez vu non alors il
nous reste béquilles ou et b qui
attendait
il va tenir tout père tranquille pendant
que je lui ai fait du mal
fallait laisser s'en tirer comme ça où
la paix arabe doit pas y aller
[Musique]
petit centime
j'ai vraiment eu six spéciales
elle était à
[Musique]